black holes are often portrayed like
this it's what looks like 2D flat space
warping into a funnel but this isn't the
whole picture this common drawing is not
a mistake but a happy accident born from
the need for Simplicity given that stars
are spherical their collapsed version is
also spherical The Event Horizon the
point of no return is not a circle but
instead is a sphere if we were inside a
black hole we would find ourselves
trapped in every smaller spheres as we
sunk deeper into its depths Bings like
this are more of a map of gravity's well
from the center it would require an
enormous amount of energy to climb out
and since black holes are symmetrical in
all directions this slice is okay to
represent the entire sphere